i'm sure a lot of you guys are wondering
how i'm doing here are a couple of
questions that you guys asked me
apart from the drama and the
conservatorship britney spears is
feeling
liberated as the pop star fights to end
her 13-year long conservatorship
a source tells et the 39 year old singer
is staying positive quote as the days go
by
brittany feels more and more liberated
mentally
emotionally and physically the source
adds that britt's boyfriend
sam esgari is quote definitely a huge
part of that
quote britney is fearless and she has
reached the point of truly feeling like
she has nothing left to lose
it's a very big deal that she's speaking
out and she has told the court
she wants her voice heard she's come to
a head and she needs to figure out what
she's gonna do about this
conservatorship
and she thinks this is the best way to
get her point across
since britney's bombshell testimonies
that she gave on june 23
and july 14 she's been spending time in
hawaii
and the source adds quote hawaii has
felt like britney's safe place lately
and that's why she has been going
basically every month
it's physically nice to distance from
the drama of what's happening
she feels free powerful and recharged
when she's there
on thursday britney's attorney filed a
motion requesting that the judge
expedite her dad jamie spears's removal
as conservator of her estate
ahead of the scheduled september 29th
hearing
in his place she requested that jason
rubin step
in as a temporary conservator i'm sure a
lot of you guys
are wondering how i'm doing following
news of her request
britt answered fan questions on
instagram and
shared an update on her well-being and
since the cat is out of the bag
literally out of the bag um and you guys
know my situation
um i do want to let you guys know things
are way better than what i ever
anticipated
later in the day she also posted about
wanting to redo her backyard
my goal um for the future is to get a
koi pond and put little um
fishy in there really excited about it
um i love my yard my house is beautiful
but it has some work to do so
here i go and she got excited about
getting her first ipad
i am so excited my kids have owned one
i've never owned one
this is just a groundbreaking day i've
always had a little phone but now this
ipad
is in my hands and i feel like my life
is changing as we speak
and i'm so excited upward bound yes
et recently spoke with iggy azalea about
why she chose to speak out in support of
brittany amid the pop star's ongoing
conservatorship battle
[Music]
the two previously worked together in
2015 on the track
pretty girls and iggy recently claimed
that while working on the collab
she quote personally witnessed the same
abusive behavior brittany detailed in
her june testimony against her father
it's not about her dad it's about
brittany you know i don't feel an
allegiance to britney spears as father
because i grew up watching her and i
idolized her and i still do and she's
really
kind lovely person and
beyond the fact that we collaborated
together she put her faith in me
[Music]